the Titan gods are a topic that I've not
really discussed in too much detail on
this channel and a lot of you have asked
me to make videos on them and I can
completely understand why there is a
host of information out there on the
primordial deities and the Olympians the
generations of gods that came before and
after but the Titans seem to suffer from
middle child syndrome almost information
on them is a lot more scarce and
unreliable but that does mean more is
left to the imagination today we'll be
taking a look at coiours the Titan of
intelligence and resolve COI is his name
roughly translated means questioning as
he was regarded as the god of the
inquisitive mind and intelligence when
Cronus castrated his father his brothers
held him in place their father was so
big that the brothers were personified
as four pillars located on each corner
of the earth coiours was regarded as the
pillar of the north or the northern pole
on the celestial axis the romans
referred to coiours as polis which is
also associated with the northern pole
koyasan his siblings were regarded as
the elder Titans
mean in the first generation children of
Uranus and Gaia and he was married to
Phoebe the tightness of radiance and
prophecy like quite a few of the other
Titans Kois didn't have a large role in
greek mythology but his children and
grandchildren however most certainly did
Koya son phoebe gave birth to levantus
the titan of the air Leto the Titan
goddess of motherhood which would make
apollo and artemis quays his
grandchildren and finally they bought
Asteria the tightness of fallen stars
which would also mean the goddess Hecate
was his granddaughter both Phoebe and
coy were thought to have ties to
cosmology and astrology and it's
something we can see they passed down to
their children and grandchildren Artemis
in Hakata having close links to the moon
and Apollo being passed down the gifts
of prophecy
there are some accounts that believe the
successor Titans had in the world the
Olympians was down to coiours being the
wisest of the Titans and with Cronus
defeated it's likely that he's intellect
and gifts of prophecy meant that Koya
skus oom the role of
or chief strategist during the war but
despite his best efforts the Titans
would eventually lose the war and
koyasan his brothers and sisters will be
banished to Tartarus there are tales of
course attempting to escape Tartarus
breaking his chains and free and his
brothers and sisters their plan came to
a halt when they reached the gate and
sword was guarded by Cerberus and the
Hydra unable to defeat Cerberus in the
Hydra the Titans would remain in
Tartarus at Zeus's behest I'd love
nothing more than to give you an
in-depth and detailed analysis of chaos
but there isn't much information about
him to me coughs was one of the first
intellectual deities in Greek mythology
his association with the celestial axis
and the heavens meant that he was seen
as possessing the power of prophecy and
that coupled of his intellect creates an
extremely powerful God a God that I wish
had been developed more as sad as it is
that we don't know much about chaos in
his grandchildren Artemis Apollo and her
Carty we have some truly fascinating
figures that do share some of their
grandfather's qualities if I had to
compare close to one of the more well
known gods and goddesses I'd say he's
pragmatic approach and inquisitive
nature reminds me of Athena and maybe
Caius was an influential figure for the
ancient Greeks during the creation of
Athena I know this video isn't
particularly long but mentions of course
a few and far and there isn't much horse
I feel I can say but I'd like to hear
what you guys think does coy remind you
of any other deities were you aware that
he was the grandfather of Artemis Apollo
and her karta was he another deity that
you didn't know existed I look forward
to hearing from you in the comments
below as always I've been your host
mythology and fiction explained